so chat poggers chat ob sie lauter
so erst mal das ganze bisschen kleiner machen
so heute probieren wir mal was aus
was hier los monka es monka giga hyper s hat bethoven heute geburtstag oder so was oder was
möchte möchte uns bing damit sagen ja der hintergrund ist das einzige was ich von bing verwende
bing image of the day lull und ich habe mein setup ein bisschen geupgraded huge upgrade
für bastler stream wir werden heute nicht viel basteln weil es ist nicht viel zeit aber aber ich
habe massive upgrade gemacht und zwar ups hat endlich geschafft mein elgato ring light zu liefern
überhaupt schon jemand da laut twitch vorschau sind sieben leute aber das ist wahrscheinlich das
gegenstück zu youtube abo box camp an nein falsch falsch sorry leute falsch hier das wohl spannend so
exzellent genau und zwar genau ich habe mir so ein teil hier geholt also einmal ring light oder
auch genau exzellent leid ehrlich gesagt ist nicht so egal so ich muss jetzt mein ring light
bevor ich euch das ganze zeigen kann muss ich erstmal mein ring light einschalten exzellent
das schöne ist an diesem ring light das funktioniert in meiner heim automatisierung
guckt mal hier glaube ich da im stream nicht gerne ein weil ich immer angst habe dass ich was liege
aber da gibt es nicht wirklich viel zu liegen gerade jetzt guck mal da elgato ring light kann
ich über meine heim automatisierung steuern inklusive inklusive farbtemperatur das ist
massive poggers zeigt euch gleich wie das ausschaut ring light für face reveal na klar
was sonst was ab aber aber ich reveal was ich ich reveal was im stream ne wobei das kennt ihr
schon weil die regelmäßig gucken kennen das glaube ich schon aber ich habe ich habe das ein
bisschen anders eingerichtet also ich mache mal hier auf dann zeige ich euch das chrome auf und
dann muss ich dahin lokal installiert jetzt kommt poggers reheizungsstatistik so muss das nur ordentlich
funktionieren und weggehen so und jetzt kann ich weil das ist ein bisschen doof ich mach
es mal ich mach es mal ein stückchen kleiner jetzt kann ich ich schiebe das mal hier rüber
das kann ich hier guck mal kann ich beleuchtung stellsen inklusive farbtemperatur und ich habe
so ein richtig so ein richtig echtes stativ da dran und sowas hier und es hat kaum noch leck
es hat es hat es hat so gut wie gar kein leck mehr jetzt seht ihr seht es hier neben guck mal
guck mal wie kurz die verzögung ist ihr seht meine hand moment hier im tablet ein bisschen
spiegelverkehrt seht ihr das wie wir also im tablet ist die also es ist wirklich wenig und
dass das tablet ist im w-lad hier am rechner ist sogar noch schneller und ich habe einen
vorschau teil ja und ich habe den den keks drinnen so genau man kann jetzt sogar die
farbtemperatur einstellen machen wir irgendwie besonders weiß oder so ja exzellent das einzige
problem ist was ich habe ich habe noch keine chat vorschau deswegen nehme ich jetzt hier
mein oldschool iphone mach einfach die chat vorschau auf richter profi stream so ja ja
geht jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt geht steil aufwärts hier leute ich sag's euch muss ich erst mal den chat auf
machen chat doch chat dann machen wir du not do not disturb an auf dem handy wie geht das überhaupt
glaube ich habe das noch nie angemacht wie geht das boomer probleme
chat wo mache ich denn auf dem alten iphone do not disturb an
das flugzeug modus nee oder den mond ach ich kann auch den kann ich geht das auch dass ich geht
das auch dass ich hier jetzt müssen wir echt ist ich komme vor wie der lehrer am video recorder
früher kann man kann man auch hier den mond drücken guck mal den da den man sieht es jetzt
schlecht hier den mond geht das auch exzellent guckt habe ich auch auf vorschau jawoll so muss das sein
legen wir das mal hier unten ein bisschen was sehe sehr schön nice so muss das sein so mal kurze
chat kommen wie hast du denn den dns zu hause gemacht um mit punktaus auf deine sachen zu
graben ich habe einen klaut dns und interner eigenen dns also über klaut fler mache ich die
ganze zertifikatsgeschichte siehst ja das ding hat ein gültiges zertifikat und alles über klaut
fler mache ich die zertifikatsgeschichte und inter löse ich halt einfach anders auf
ja jepp
sach ja wie der lehrer früher so jetzt können wir das hier mal auf einen anderen desktop schieben
zum einstellen so und jetzt kann man dem kram irgendwie sagen dass der diese komischen controls
aus oh picture in picture geht auch da kamen ja massive big brain moves machen ihr guckt
euch das mal an ne naja ok nicht wirklich nicht wirklich dass man kann man keine wirklich großartig
big brain moves mit machen kannst du dann auch von außen drauf zu kann ne will ich ja gar
der sinn will ich ja nicht show control jetzt guck mal der chat wieder der chat ist wieder
so massive brain das gibt es nicht und jetzt kann ich nämlich fullscreen machen irgendwie
so bäm und jetzt blendet er den scheiß hoffentlich da oben aus und zack komm mal hier ist das nicht
nice so die belichtung müsste jetzt auch besser sein als das letzte mal also hier guck
sieht viel natürlicher aus jetzt man sieht hier wieder oh ey leute ich muss ich was zeigen
und habe ich habe ich genug entknotet weißt du ob es einfach ist sich einen p hole pie hole ich
weiß nicht wie man das un wie man das anständig ausspricht ohne dass es unanständig klickt auf
raspberry pie zu machen ja das ist relativ einfach die haben sogar einen fertigen install
den machst du einfach auf die sd karte und dann geht's das können wir mal im stream eigentlich
machen aber das ist wirklich einfach du gehst du gehst einfach hier die haben hier die haben
irgendwo den download und das machst du dir einfach auf die sd karte
hatten die nicht mal ein fertiges image was ich auf die sd karte machen kann ich meine
du kannst einfach hier drauf entzählen hatten die nicht früher mal ein fertiges image
mal gut keine ahnung das haben wir das letzte mal ausprobiert das hat nicht gut funktioniert
da ist mir schlecht geworden bei mit wenn die kamera andersrum ist wenn ich zu sehr wackel
dann dann okay da muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen das andere war vielleicht ein bisschen wackel
resistenter muss man mal gucken wobei der tisch der tisch ist wirklich schon ziemlich
ziemlich massiv hier also der wackelt gar nicht mal so einfach aber die das ring light
an diesem stativ wackelt glaube ich relativ viel müssen wir mal ausprobieren genau also
das das kommt ja und ich drehe mich mal kurz um chat ich sehe euch jetzt nur noch hier
unten ja das ist tatsächlich moment was warum macht mein iphone den den chat aus wenn ich
den ach muss ich jetzt video anmachen dass ich dass es sich nicht ausschaltet oder was
oder low brain apple tactics guckt mal übrigens hier die kratz hat wieder voll zugeschlagen
mal hier stößt mal an ja kratzortz ok wunderbar also chat wie gesagt es gibt da nicht so wahnsinnig
viele sachen die mehr machen können was beatport ist der billigste shit speedport ist halt dabei
also wir haben es letztes mal probiert mit der kamera drehen das hat nicht so gut funktioniert
die kratze ist nicht aggressiv die kratze ist eigentlich ganz lieb die macht normalerweise
eigentlich nix wenn ich aber anfangen mit der katz irgendwie blöd rumzuspielen dann
dann fängt die da halt und wenn und wenn du dann den armen weg ziehst da kommt dann
hier halt so dinger raus naja so also das ist ganz schön warm der kram hier oben f ist jetzt
das da schwitzt man ja richtig wenn man davon ins sich geknallt kriegt jetzt weiß ich auch
warum die tagesschau typen immer so schwitzen aber leute was sagt ihr ist die beleuchtung
besser also ich finde ich finde die deutlich ausgewogener die beleuchtung als das letzte
mal guck mal die ist richtig gleichmäßig hier verteilt und das gute ist man hat auch
keine schatten weil das handy das handy das hängt genau hier zwischen zwischen dem licht
guck mal das ist sogar so gut dass man den staub den staub auf der lötstation vorne
sieht sag mal welche auflösung hat die kam ist die auflösung schlechter könnt ihr
sagen mal könnt ihr das ne die auflösung könnt ihr lesen oder der autofokus sagt
halt ein bisschen das sollte df robot oder sowas drauf sind alle kamera autofokus blitz
blitz autofokus hier df robot ja doch das erkennt man gut doch ich glaube die auflösung
passt halbwegs glaube die auflösung ist nicht wesentlich schlechter als das letzte mal
eats atomfred fünf monat dankeschön dankeschön also hier das ich glaube die auflösung ist
wirklich ganz gut kann man das kann man das irgendwie sehen kann man hier irgendwie irgendwie
sehen was das für eine anscheinend nicht ist auch ist auch egal doch ich kann das in
obs einbinden die sache ist nur die wenn ich das in obs einbinde da kriege ich nicht weg
hier ist easy hier kann ich einfach weg switchen weißte hier kann ich einfach weg switchen
und in obs nicht ja leute ich zeige euch mal was was ich mir gekauft habe ich wollte ich
wollte ich wie gesagt wir haben nichts wir haben nichts großartig wollte man nur das
setup ein bisschen ausprobieren ob das setup was taugt und also ich ich muss zwei boards
noch die header dran löten das ist jetzt nichts spannendes aber das können wir machen
dass man mal sieht wie die wie die ausleuchtung ist und wie das alles passt und es wackelt
aber nix wenn ich hier normal am tisch bin wenn ich glaube wenn ich normal am tisch bin
wackelt nix das ist nur wenn ich hier mister drauf haustellen macht dann dann wackelts
normalerweise ja jetzt muss ich erst mal wieder ein pendeln ne ne normalerweise ist da nix
alles klar gut also wir müssen ein paar header dran löten und dann habe ich mir sowas hier
gekauft ich weiß nicht ob ihr das kennt weil ich habe keinen plan wie man es genau verwendet
aber es sah in der vorschau gut aus zwar sowas hier guck mal vielleicht kennt vielleicht
kennt das einer von euch sowas hier damit kann man angeblich kabels in einem schritt
zusammen löten und gleichzeitig schrumpfschlauch abdichten habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
also testen wir mal ich habe hier ich habe hier eine rolle ich habe hier so eine rolle
kabloors da werden wir das gleich mal ausprobieren ob das was taugt so ich wollte noch was zu
diesen boards sagen weil wir hatten jetzt ja schon ein paar esp 32 boards und das sind
von den größeren sind das echt meine lieblings boards die gut der vorteil davon ist sagt
soll jetzt ja nicht zur verkaufsveranstaltung verkommen aber ich wollte trotzdem trotzdem
was zu sagen das sind low power boards die brauchen nur ungefähr ich muss das übrigens
anders machen stelle ich gerade fest mit meinem setup hier sonst sehe ich meine vorschau ja
selber nicht das mal so machen hoffe ich liege mich jetzt nicht da drauf aber weiß ja nie
muss ich das dahin machen die vorschau muss ich irgendwie hier so sagt da muss ich irgendwie
noch was drunter legen weil weil sonst sehe ich meine vorschau selbst gar nicht richtig
und macht auch mal hoch kann besser funktioniert da kann man auch rein zoomen okay das ist
auch nicht verkehrt dann dann lasse ich das lasse ich das doch hier hinten das doch ein
bisschen besser egal habs auch ich sehe wenn ich ungefähr in welcher das ist alles braucht
noch ein bisschen brauche ein bisschen setup so also genau was ich sagen wollte das sind
low power boards die haben einen ganz normalen esp 32 drauf also sprich zwei kerne 240 megahertz
aber die brauchen im deep sleep bloß um die 10 microampere also das ist schon ziemlich
wenig und damit habe ich auch diesen bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor auf dem friedhof gebastelt der jetzt gerade
nicht mehr läuft aber das hat andere gründe die halten mit so einer 0815 batterie locker
einen jahr eher zwei wenn man halt nicht alle fünf minuten was schickt ist eigentlich ganz
praktisch ja genau da müssen wir nur noch ein paar headers dranlöten kann man nämlich
gleich ausprobieren wie das hier funktioniert ich habe hier meine meine header kiste krassen
header alter hier was wir da brauchen also ich muss sagen so der das setup ist noch
nicht so der wahnsinn ich glaube den chat lege ich einfach hier unten zwischen unten
drauf genau da kann ich dem das ist gut ich habe jetzt den chat hier unten liegen da kann
ich einfach noch unten gucken und sehen den chat das ist gut das gefällt mir das da kommt
das hin exzellent so jetzt müssen wir mal eine runde header suchen wie gesagt das ist
nicht weil ich das jetzt unbedingt bräuchte sondern einfach nur ok mal da die sind zu
lang mein ich kann was abschneiden aber habe ich da nichts passendes mehr mal gucken hier
das da besser ah ja ok das das schon mal besser allerdings ist es ein ziemlicher low brain
header den brauche ich da in dieser form da garantiert nicht dran und nimmt viel zu
viel platz weg was auch so irgendwas spannendes was man dafür verwenden könnte was zum was
das alles sind glaube ich die dinge die beim raspberry dabei sind dankeschön für den
sub prodigy t hey das ist richtig gut wenn ich hier unten den kram liegen habe da sehe
ich auch wenn im chat was ist haben wir hier noch irgendwelche das könnte auch gut passen
oder ist auch zu fett sagt bloß ich habe keine header mehr für das zeug sieht nicht so
aus sieht nicht so aus als habe ich dafür eine ordentliche heller das sagt aber dann
machen wir dann machen wir so ein klein dran da machen wir so ein klein das passt dann
war ich so ein klein dran zumindest für für strom ground und ja hier einfach mal zum
ausprobieren wie gesagt ich will eh nur das set up testen das reicht auch erst einmal
weil ich meine das hier unten ist falsche seite das hier unten ist einmal ground und
gpio 3,3 volt das reicht erstmal so mini header easy so aber vorher will ich immer den kram
hier ausprobieren habe ich mir extra gekauft weil ich gedacht habe das könnte wirklich
was praktisches sein hände liegt oh mein gott schau wieder warum habe ich denn da nicht
dran gedacht dass ich die hände liegt fack was machen jetzt leute ich habe die hände
gelegt scheiße press f für die hände also ich packe das mal schnell aus so und wie das
angeblich funktioniert ist folgendes umweltschützer hassen diesen trick so wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe funktioniert das folgendermaßen man macht wie geht denn das überhaupt auf
das ist schon mal das erste das ist für low brain leute nicht geeignet das funktioniert
das geht nicht auf so man nimmt sich irgendwie so ein teil isoliert das kabel ab und dann
schiebt man von beiden richtungen des kabel da links und rechts rein und dann ah dann
braucht man heiß luft brauche man da heiß luft steht da irgendwie drauf wie das funktioniert
dann braucht man heiß luft feuerzeug habe ich keins aber ich kann mein heiß ich kann
mein heiß luft teil holen das ist ok feuerzeug habe ich keins zumindest jetzt hier nicht
greifbeiner ich probiere das mal im heiß luft ich habe das noch nie gemacht bin ich mal
gespannt ob das wie das funktioniert weil das wäre ganz praktisch gerade diese kleinen
hier man muss man muss ja öfters mal irgendwelche sensorkabel oder so verlängern und da machst
du normalerweise immer ab isolieren schrumpfschlauch drauf zusammengelöten zu dings drüber schrumpfschlauch
schrumpfen da wäre so ein ding viel praktischer gucken wir mal ob das was taucht ich gehe
mal kurz ich gehe mal kurz der heiß luft heiß luft holen oh leute china crap guck mal
ist schon kaputt das schloss ist schon kaputt ist ja äußerst stabil der metallring in der
mitte muss man den zusammendrücken nee ich glaube der metallring in der mitte ist kein
richtiger metallring um um metallring zu sein sondern das ist glaube ich lötsin soweit
ich das verstanden habe also sprich hier in der mitte ist ein bisschen lötsin drinne und
dann steckt man links und rechts das kabel rein und und heiß luftet das und dann schmilzt
das lötsin und die kabel gehen zusammen irgendwie soweit die theorie wir haben gesagt foggits
dankeschön prodigy auch bei dir danke für den sub max du hast wurstfinger nicht nur
das auch dicke arme wissen wir ja der atom fred ist auch am start den habe ich schon
gesehen den habe ich schon gesehen ich sehe der chat mag keine speedports von der telekom
mag auch keine speedports von der telekom aber ich muss sagen an der telekom regt mich noch
andere sachen auf das ist nicht speedport ist das kleinste das kleinste problem was mich
an der telekom nervt so ok ich gehe mal ganz schnell mein heißluft stellz holen und dann
gucken wir mal wie der kram funktioniert ich bin in einer minute wieder da
die
OBS-Ninja schwer einzurichten, nee einfach klonen statischer Web-Server fertig
überhaupt überhaupt kein Ding
ich habe übrigens was vergessen
vergessen den Chat aufzumachen
dass wir nachher noch ein paar Sachen angucken können erst mal Dark Mode sonst werden alle blind
Venis Unleashed
wird am 21.12. veröffentlicht sie suchen aktuell noch Personen die das pushen da bin ich dabei
wird es wird Hardcore gepusht alter
da bin ich dabei ist halt die Frage was die gepusht haben wollen ich mein Video zu mache ich auf jeden fall wenn das rauskommt
so das allerwichtigste für die Entspannung
ich habe den Eindruck die Kamera war das letzte mal ein Ticken schärfer aber das das liegt wahrscheinlich einfach nur daran dass
das ist mit der Beleuchtung jetzt anders ist ich glaube nicht ich glaube nee oder Chat man konnte noch nie man konnte noch nie hier lesen was da drauf steht von so weit weg oder nee oder was ist das denn
was ist denn Venis Unleashed das ist ein Modpack für Battlefield 3
dass du Custom Server machen kannst, Plaufelder ausschalten kannst, Leute können Custom Mods skripten und so eigentlich eine richtig coole Geschichte
was ich ein bisschen bedenken habe muss ich ehrlich sagen was Venis Unleashed angeht
dass ein Modding Framework ist das eine aber wenn ein Modding Framework rauskommt ohne Content für den für den normalen Spieler dann wird es dann ist das halt instant uninteressant
das ist so das bedenken was ich habe ich mein es ist sehr nice wenn es Mods gibt oder weil man Mods machen kann aber wenn das rauskommt wenn es da nichts irgendwie zu holen gibt für den normalen Spieler dann ist das halt instant uninteressant
deswegen habe ich da so ein bisschen meine Bedenken was ich heute bastle ganz ehrlich ich teste nur das Setup
ja es gibt bereits einige Mods aber es müsste halt irgendwie so ein offizielles Aushängeschild geben
ja sei es halt einfach nur verbesserte Rush oder irgendwas oder ein bisschen irgendwas so bringt ja nichts wenn es ein paar Mods gibt es muss halt irgendwas geben wo die Leute auch gerne spielen wollen
weil ansonsten ist halt schwierig was vor allem was willst du zum Beispiel so eine Videos sagen sagst hey nice Venis Unleashed ist raus die Leute können jetzt Mods erstellen
das ist die erste Frage dann kommt ja und was gibt es halt schon geiles oder oder oder oder was gibt es halt schon zu spielen wo es so ein ja eigentlich nix so ein paar Experimente
das Ding war jetzt 10 Jahre in Entwicklung und es gibt halt ein paar Experimente das das Interesse ist halt instant weg
also ich versetze mich da jetzt in Zuschauersicht rein ich finde es geil dass es das gibt aber hm deswegen ich freue mich da richtig drauf dass das rauskommt aber ich hab da so meine Bedenken
so Lance ich bin auch gespannt wie das funktioniert normalerweise löte ich den Krempel auch aber wir probieren das jetzt mal aus also erstmal Heißluft mach ich mal weg das ist so ein Ding hier das da keine Ahnung ich brauch für alles reflings mittlerweile hab ich gemerkt
ich hab dieses Video gemacht mit Geschenken und so das hat schon über 150€ also ich hab ja auch noch ein paar Videos gemacht die ich noch nicht ausgesucht habe es ist halt ein bisschen zu spät
und so das hat schon über 150 euro einfach so weil weil rafflings easy easy
fack easy money easy life so sieht es aus so dann machen wir mal hier ein stück
kabel ab und gucken uns das ganze an was sagst du zum allzeit hoch bitcoin kurs
dann sage ich dass ich mir hätte bitcoin kaufen sollen
ne du weißt alter was das sag mal warum stauben manche kabel ok das war eine
rhetorische frage ich weiß warum das so ist es gibt kabel die haben so so was
ist total oder irgendwas drinne dass ist dass das wenn das halbwegs elastisch ist
dass die dass die isolierung nicht reißen sowas in drinnen so als probieren
das mal aus dass wir machen jemand stückchen ab oh ich habe die ops ich
glaube ich habe den ich habe den seitensteller dabei ein bisschen zu
klein ist ok komm mal gucken ob das knipper zeug sein geld wert ist ja so
denn das ist definitiv nicht für so fette kabel gemacht
alter ok
wow ach du scheiß muss es hingeflogen das ging ab wie die rakete wo ist es hin
ah dahinten liegt es liegt an der komplett anderen ende des raumes das ist
abgezischt wie nix besser besser wie das neue spaceship
spaceship so probieren wir das mal aus sollen wir aber wieder den altbekannten
und bewährten ab isoliert schämt übrigens ist kein staub der hier fliegt
das ist dieses komische pulver aus dem kabel guckt euch das mal an hier
drogen stream konfront so dass übrigens das war auch eine frage hier letztens
jemand hatte mit dieser zange also man kann damit auch dickere kabel
abisolieren aber also mehr als das hier wird schwierig weil man wird gleich
sehen ich versuche ich das mal kurz ob ich das euch zeigen kann
mach mal kurz hier ein bisschen bisschen weiter hinter wenn man das hier rein
macht man sieht schon also das geht noch aber mehr ist da eigentlich auch net
net drinne guckt wenn ich jetzt hier drücke der isoliert das zwar ab aber so
hundertprozentig sauber ist es schon nicht mehr also gut mal wegen diesem
komischen pulver sauber ist hier grad eh nix aber
nee also mehr als die kabel gehen ich aber auch ehrlich sagen so fette kabel
hat man normalerweise beim basteln gar nicht
holen wir mal eins raus machen ach so wie machen wir das jetzt überhaupt wir
brauchen ja zwei seiten ok dann wir nehmen wir nehmen einfach mal zwei wir
nehmen einfach mal zwei die wir zusammen zusammen zusammen dingsen was ist das
denn für zeug ich hoffe es ist nicht giftig oder so
ich nachher muss ich nachher abmachen so jetzt ist natürlich die preisfrage
wie weit muss man das machen da bin ich mal gespannt wie weit muss man das machen
also ich würde sagen die kabel sind ja relativ dünn dann haben wir mal die hier
nehmen wir mal den roten so wie weit muss man das jetzt abmachen
also ich würde sagen so
so
ist das talg ich glaube das ist halt ja also ich glaube das ist nichts giftiges
aber was was man wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt einatmen will also wenn ich
mir das so angucke da muss ich da muss ich den ab isoliert
schämt wirklich komplett hinter stellen dass das funktioniert so schauen wir mal
so einmal ab isolieren
ja so ok ich bin ja ich bin ja echt mal gespannt ob der kram funktioniert
und jetzt und jetzt und das jetzt da rein machen so und und dann heißluft
drauf pusten oder wie
ok nächstes problem ist ich habe keine unterlage dafür und ich habe jetzt zu
wenig platz das heißt ich muss erst mal ein bisschen platz machen
das war der ab isoliert schämt muss weg der keks bleibt da der muss der ganze
sache bei wohnen sonst geht es nicht die boards mussten auf jeden fall weg das
kabel kann da bleiben der kann auch da bleiben
so ich kann das einfach auf der unterlage hier machen so ich bräuchte
jetzt eigentlich was zum darunter legen was habe ich denn hier ich habe hier
nichts großartig festes wir gucken einfach mal was die unterlage aushält
würde ich sagen schauen wir mal so das ist doch übelster kram wie soll das
jetzt dass ob das hält
ok ich bin äußerst skeptisch
popo s kannst du im archiv wahrscheinlich finden ja so ich überlege
gerade vielleicht mal wisst ihr was ich glaube ich mache das doch mit einem
feuerzeug weil mit einem feuerzeug kann man das viel besser erwärmen als so aber
ich habe kein feuerzeug was mache ich hole mit wisst ihr was ich mache leute ich hole
mir einfach eine spitze zange und halte das hier fest auf der einen seite und
dann wird und dann wird dran dran wird dran gebläst
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus muss mal kurz zeigen ob ich natürlich nicht hier
und jetzt bin ich mal echt gespannt ob das funktioniert also
komm her fön dürfte der warmste firm der der heißeste fön der welt sein also
wenn man keine haare mehr haben will ist das bestimmt ein super fön
so ich war mal kurz hier mein stuhl bis sie weg das platz haben und stell mich
mal da davor also da war erst mal hier den stecker nahe
excellent so und nu ups ich habe ein bisschen wenig platz
so und jetzt machen wir das hier rein so das da halt mal fest ich habe wirklich
keine ahnung ob immer das recht so wobei ich kann das ja nicht richtig mit der
zange halten moment moment es sagt so wie ich das mache jetzt und jetzt
puste ich da mal dran leute ich habe legit keine ahnung wie das wie das geht
und ob das geht und ob der keks das aushält das heißt ich puste mal ein
bisschen zur seite also
ich habe es jetzt nicht so hoch gemacht ich will mir nicht die bude abfangen
schmilzt das jetzt
ich meine warm genug muss sein
und jetzt hat es bringt es jetzt immer hat es
und ich greife das jetzt nicht an leute
das ist ordentlich warm der schlauch ist ja auch geschmolzen
ok man kann es angreifen leute
oh nee es war nicht heiß genug
ok ok jetzt wisst ihr was volle pulle excellent so stufe acht bärm stufe acht volle pulle easy
so vielleicht sollte ich das vielleicht sollte ich das besser hatte mal vielleicht
sollte ich das besser da angreifen also postchamp
nice guckt mal ich glaube das ist das ist richtig gut zusammen jetzt
jetzt machen wir doch den schlauch richtig zusammen
sogar die unter die unterlage hat ein bisschen aber die biegt sich wieder
zurück also das ding ist sehr stabil so jetzt jetzt hat es glaube ich funktioniert
ok das ist ganz nice also ich glaube also ich glaube mit einem also ich glaube mit
einem feuerzeug ist es angenehmer als mit so einem heißluft teil aber guckt mal da ist
jetzt wirklich das lutz hin reingelaufen was wird hier gebastelt heute nix ich teste nur
grad mein setup mit dem neuen licht ob das funktioniert
das gute an dem solches das kühlt relativ schnell ab ja nice nice guckt mal weil ich
muss man da vorschauen aber das jetzt ordentlich erkennt wenn sie es mal
fokussiert das ist jetzt richtig richtig zusammen gelaufen also sprich der scheiß
ist auch wirklich echt echt messen fest ja ok das ist cool das ist cool und das
ist auch mehr oder weniger dicht dicht also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob es wasser
dicht ist aber es ist schon ziemlich ziemlich zusammen hat sich schon ziemlich
zusammen ok das gefühlt finde ich cool das hat was was hast du denn gemacht
eigene leds das letzte mal haben wir eigentlich leds gemacht ja das hier das
ist einfach nur was war ich mir gekauft habe ich mal ausprobieren wollte und zwar
ich habe mir so einen pack von so komischen kabel zusammen also selbst wie
heißt wie nennt man den kram überhaupt insulated wire connectors also sprich
das ist so eine mischung aus schrumpf schlauch mit lötsin in der mitte hier
ist ein bisschen lötsin in der mitte und das hier mit dem schrumpfschlauch hier
machst du die kabel rein und wenn du das heiß machst dann schrumpft das zusammen
schließt das soweit die theorie wasser dicht ab und verlötet die kabel
miteinander also an sich eigentlich eine ziemlich coole sache gerade wenn man
irgendwelche sensoren verlängert oder so und dann ist es halt immer ein bisschen
nervig wenn er dann erst mal schrumpfschlauch drüber ziehen muss
da muss den kram zusammen löten schrumpfschlauch drüber schrumpfen und das
ist eigentlich eigentlich ganz nice eigentlich ganz nice also du musst sagen
gefällt mir es ist es ist bomben fest zusammen da gibt es nix es ist auch nix
aus der isolierung irgendwie raus gestochen oder so es ist eine sache ist
eine sache ist hier nicht so schön dran man kann es jetzt nicht mehr knicken
also dadurch dass das lötsin und zeug hier verlaufen ist also ich kann das hier
guckt ich kann das hier in der mitte nicht mehr knicken also sprich mir
sieht es ja hier das ganze ding ist voll mit mit mit diesem lötsin kram das heißt
wenn man kabel braucht was danach noch ein bisschen flexibel ist dann geht es
damit nicht ja aber an sich ganz coole sache eigentlich ein selbst löten der
schrumpfschlauch ist eigentlich nice muss sagen hat was hat was
ok jetzt habe ich aber ausprobiert das ist ja leute also meine frage jetzt an
euch wie findet ihr die beleuchtung jetzt ist das ok ist das besser als das
letzte mal ich meine der kram hat immerhin 200 euro gekostet ja da muss es
schon da muss es schon ordentlich besser sein
die beleuchtung also die beleuchtung ist auf jeden fall gleichmäßiger muss man
sagen die beleuchtung ist auf jeden fall gleichmäßige
dazwischen verteilt was man sagen muss was mich ein bisschen was wir noch mal
kurz ausprobieren müssen ist die die lichttemperatur
das letzte mal hatte ich nämlich eher sowas hier an lichttemperatur
ja aber was was findet ihr ist es besser komplett kühl oder eher eher warm also
warm ist das ist zu das ist zu cozy ja so das hier ist so als ich muss sagen
eigentlich finde ich das komplett kühl fast fast am besten
wobei ein bisschen mehr in der mitte so so in der in dem dreh ist glaube ich
ganz gut ja sowas hier würde ich auch sagen so
hier passt eigentlich ganz gut
da mal
brightness ist da gar kein so großer unterschied ich meine die helligkeit
von dem licht leute ist brutal ja das hat was 2700 lumen und das ist quasi
direkt drüber das ist mega hell das iphone checkt das überhaupt nicht dass
es so hell ist dass das ich glaube das iphone macht
irgendwie aber guck mal es ist überhaupt kein unterschied zwischen 100 prozent
und also kaum ein unterschied zwischen zwischen zwischen 50 prozent und 100
prozent kaum ein unterschied das iphone fängt das irgendwie ab was
irgendwie sagt er hat mal eine frage und zwar man muss mal rüber scrollen
und zwar zum raspberry pi 400 wäre die leistung ausreichend ja also die mag
vielleicht ausreichend sein aber das sagt ich verstehe ich muss ich mir
ehrlich sagen ich verstehe die begeisterung für diesen raspberry pi 400
nicht das ist denn so eine tastatur wo man raspberry einbauen kann was genau
das also ich verstehe es jetzt ernsthaft nicht ich will es nicht schlecht mal ich
verstehe es wirklich nicht macht das nicht automatischen weisabgleich ja
wahrscheinlich wo ist der vorteil davon gegenüber dem raspberry pi und einfach
eine usb oder eine bluetooth tastatur und man ist unabhängig davon und hat
nicht so eine kacktastatur ich meine die tastatur sackt bestimmt richtig
weniger kabel bei bluetooth naja also ich weiß dass das total beliebt ist aktuell
aber ich verstehe nicht genau warum ehrlich gesagt ja und ich denke mal es
hat zum rumbasteln sicherlich ausreichend um damit java zu programmieren
aber spaß wird das keiner machen generell desktop desktop betrieb und
gerade so fette sachen laufen lassen wie ein intelli j im studio code da ist der
raspberry pi eigentlich ein bisschen schwachbrüstig für also wenn ich wenn
ich wirklich daheim was bräuchte so in dieser form da würde ich mir eher ein
kleines x86 system kaufen und bluetooth tastatur oder am besten gleich ordentlich
tastatur dran weil ich glaube wirklich großartig programmieren möchte man ja
mit dieser mit dieser tastatur auch nicht
es sei denn wir haben bestimmt im chat welche die die schwören auf flache
tastaturen ja aber ich finde zum programmieren braucht es eine richtig
ordentliche full-size tastatur mit numblock und allem dabei
iphone ballast halt so auch wenn du dunkler machst ja anscheinend
ja dafür ist es sicherlich nicht verkehrt
dafür ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt
torque
wann musst du wieder arbeiten
an
am
sag ich dir
am fünften
so by the way wie nennt sich nochmal dieses zeug
irgendjemand hat es doch im chat vorher geschrieben
wie nennt sich nochmal dieses zeug in diesem kabel
irgendwas mit talc ne
kabel talc
ok
da suchen wir mal
krebs erregend
giftig
dem zufolge kanns was
monkaS
was da ist asbest
das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
ach ne, heute eingesetztes talc
jedoch sei in seiner
reinigen
form asbest frei und daher nicht
krebs erregend
ok also besser
nicht einatmen
so also ich also
heute ist das anscheinend nicht mehr krebs erregend
gut
gut zu wissen, gut zu wissen
mein kabel ist neu, das hab ich vom jahr gekauft
oder vom halben jahr
die gefahr lauert im baby
puder
alles klar
gut also es ist
definitiv nix was man einatmen will
so viel ist schonmal
sicher
von lötverbindung zu baby puder
ja aber
der kram ist
in den kabeln drinne damit
also
dieses pulver ist hier drinne
das sind ja starre
und wenn du die biegst
und die aneinander reiben, dann geht die isolierung kaputt
ich werd das einfach mal lüften danach
interessant
ja
müsste das nicht drauf stehen
wenn das irgendwie asbesthaltig ist oder so
ja
ne ist bestimmt nicht
ich glaube da muss man sich keine sorgen machen
also wir haben für jeden scheiß irgendwelche regulierungen
dann werden wir das da auch haben
okay
gut
okay also
ich werd jetzt nicht instant f
pressen müssen
aber ich ja dann selbst eh nicht mehr
wird schon irgendeiner dien norm entsprechen
ja bestimmt
wenn ich das jetzt so sehe
dann bräuchte ich nur noch einen mini staubsauger
um den kram wegzumachen
diena 4 0 w
wahrscheinlich putzt man das am besten mit ein bisschen
mit ein bisschen
nassen papier oder so auf
ja
okay leute, dann löte ich jetzt noch mal schnell den header dran
also
ja
okay leute, dann löte ich jetzt noch mal schnell den header dran
an das eine board
dass wir das hinter uns haben
da können wir auch mal kurz checken
wie die quali ist
wenn man hier Sachen löte
ob man da noch alles sieht
noch mal hier das board
board w
machen wir die lötstation an
mal gucken ob man die irgendwie so hingestellt kriegt
dass man was sieht
kriegt man die vielleicht irgendwie so hingestellt
also ich probiere das mal kurz
wenn das was
seht ihr die temperatur
ich sehe in meiner vorschau nix richtig
die müsste jetzt 200
jetzt hat 300
viel zu heiß
warum wird das immer wärmer
normalerweise sollte es bei spätestens 380 aufhören
was?
ich muss gerade mal in meine vorschau gucken
ja sieht man doch eigentlich ganz gut
passt doch
sieht doch eigentlich echt ganz
brauchbar aus, weil sieht man wenigstens was das ding
wenn temperatur hat
okay
ich machs mal busy
ich bin gerade in meine host gefahren
ich machs mal ein bisschen
mach mal kurz ein bisschen
temperatur runter
noch mal 380
330 oder sowas
reicht ja dicke
ich glaub was braucht man dass das anfängt zu schmelzen
270, 260 oder irgendwas
brauchst du ja für so kleinkram wirklich nicht viel
so wo haben wir denn den header
ich geb dir header
so gut zackzack
noch mal die zange weg
volle pulle
jetzt mal, das ist eine gute frage
komm wir probieren mal aus was volle pulle ist
ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
ich weiß nicht was maximale temperatur bei dem ding ist
probieren wir mal aus
400, 450
seh ich das richtig
probieren wir mal aus
450 hochgefahren
poc
ordentlich
chat, chat, wollt ihr mal dran greifen
so
also ich mein
fahr mal das ding mal wieder runter
aber 330
ok wunderbar
so da wollen wir mal
oh wo hab ich schon mein lutz hin
das brauch ich auf jeden fall
so
ich aufwickel den kram
so also was
brauche ich denn von dem board
ich brauche hier
wenn schon überhaupt das hier
3,3 volt
ground und 2 gpi aus
ok dann machen wir das mal so
ja der tisch ist ein ticken zu hoch
der tisch ist ein ticken zu hoch
deswegen seh ichs nicht so gut
ich überleg grad wie es am sinnvollsten ist
wie ich den kram verbaue
wahrscheinlich mach ich so in die
so in die
kiste
eventu
ja wobei ne ne passt
hier oben ist ja eh der anschluss für die batterie
dann ist das so eigentlich ganz sinnvoll
das so zu machen
das müssen wir mal gucken dass wir das gerade hinbekommen
mal gucken ob man das alles gut erkennt
weil wirklich
großartigen
großartigen sinn dass ich das jetzt mache
hat es nicht
jetzt erstmal unmittelbar nicht
ich seh nix das ist mein problem
das gerade
oh
ja
halbwegs
bis sie bis sie bis sie nach rechts
können wir das noch machen
jetzt ist gut
jetzt ist
guck mal also
viel gräder kann das nicht sein
guckt euch das mal an
exellent
so
den kram dran
das ist echt doof ich glaube ich muss es so kippen
dann seh ich n bisschen mehr
so da machen wir jetzt hier die andere
seite also ich mach das meistens so
ich mach auf der einen seite einmal dran und dann
auf der anderen seite einmal dran und jetzt sollte es
eigentlich
kack
und dann ist es
ja eh fest und dann
ich fast egal was man macht
also ich muss sagen
ich hab sie normalerweise auf 380
den unterschied merkt man
insofern
braucht n bisschen länger bis es warm wird
wer hätte das gedacht
und leute sind
dämpfe sind dämpfe aus dem
löten auch giftig
bestimmt
alles ist alles giftig
alles giftig
da ist wahrscheinlich plei drinne in den dämpfen
und dann ist auch krebs erregend
alles ist alles giftig und krebs erregend
ok exquisite
sehr gut
so passt
hey das riecht gut geworden das ist ja mal
ich glaube ohne scheiß so gerade habe ich
noch nie was dran gekriegt das ist ja wirklich
du erkennst ja wenn du von oben drauf guckst du erkennst
nichts also
es ist weder nach da noch
es ist weder nach da es ist wirklich das
könnte vom
china fließband gelaufen sein das ding
nice
gut ich hoffe man hat auch so alles
erkannt zwar jetzt ja
setup setup test stream
ihr habt wahrscheinlich
mehr gesehen als ich weil ich sitze
ja irgendwie hier so
schräg so und sehe eigentlich kaum was
bewerbung der
foxconn ist raus
sind foxconn
sind foxconn nicht die
wo die leute vom dach gesprungen sind
und dann
ihnen vertraglich untersagt wurde
vom dach zu springen
was ja auch
absolut big brain logic
ist die leute springen dir vom dach
weil die arbeitsbedingungen so scheiße sind
und was machst du den leuten untersagen vom
dach zu springen
das bringt bestimmt was also das ist
wahnsinnig effektiv
ist
ist mittlerweile
pleihaltiges lötzchen für den privat
gebrauch nicht mehr erhältlich
also soweit ich weiß
ist das für den privat gebrauch noch
ok und das was ich
hier hab ich mein da ist auch noch ein bisschen
was drauf
ähm
das ist auch
ich weiß gar nicht ob man das irgendwo sieht
aber das ist auf jeden
fall pleihaltiges lötzchen
was weiß ich 80 20
70 30 hier steht es doch guck mal
kupf was
kupfer
ok ich hab von chemik keine ahnung aber
allein schon wenn da 3 sachen drauf stehen
spricht dafür dass das pleihaltiges ist
pb ist das
und
sch ist das zin
ich hab kein blassen schimmer von
ok pb ist pleih
plumpum ah yes
sie ist der chat hier lernt man noch was
im stream
und sch ist wahrscheinlich dann zin
c
u ist ja eigentlich kupfer
aber es ist c u 6
c u 2
irgendwie spezielles Kupfer, Isotope oder so. Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Normalerweise ist das ja so, also ich weiß nicht wie das hier ist, ne?
Normalerweise ist es ja so, das was hinter dem Element dran steht,
ist die Zahl der zusätzlichen Neutronen im Atomkern.
Oder?
Chet, erzähl dich Mist!
Also, ich hab keine Ahnung ob das jetzt hier der Fall ist, aber normalerweise hast du,
ähm, wenn du dranstehen hast sowas wie, keine Ahnung,
ähm, Uran 68 oder sowas, dann hast du 68 zusätzliche...
Das sind Prozent, jaja, in dem Fall schon, aber wenn du bei Elementen
sowas hinten dranstehen hast, keine Ahnung, Uran 68 oder Uran 150 oder sowas,
dann sind das doch die zusätzlichen
Teile im Atom, also die neutralen Teile zusätzlich im Atomkern oder sowas, ne?
Ach, die schreibt man vorne dran. Alter, heute ist ja mal richtig,
mehr gelernt heute als die ganzen 10 Jahre Chemie.
Genau, Anzahl der Neutronen im Kern, stimmt, genau.
So, und das ist ja dann irgendwie so, dass wenn du dann, ähm,
dass die, dass die, dass diese Elemente hier sind ja chemisch,
so, mehr oder weniger gleich, ne?
Die Neutronenanzahl macht es da nicht aus, aber
es gibt dann doch irgendwelche Unterschiede, zum Beispiel, also was ich weiß ist,
wenn man, wenn man Uran haben will, was in einem Atomkraftwerk funktioniert,
ich weiß, Big Brain Stream, ja, dann geht nicht einfach normales,
normales Uran, dann braucht man irgendwie angereichertes Uran mit mehr,
mit mehr Neutronen im Kern, ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht warum,
dass man es besser trifft oder so, weil kein Schimmer.
Zumindest funktioniert normales nicht, so, aber ich habe von Chemie keinen Plan.
Genau, nur Uran 235, ja.
Siehst du, in der Chat weiß das, ich nicht.
Big Brain Chat, exquisite.
Warum muss man das anreichern, dass man es besser trifft?
Das kann ja nicht sein, ja.
Also ich meine, bei einer Atombombe würde ich es ja noch verstehen,
weil ich meine, da muss ja irgendwas da reinschießen,
dass es dann anfängt, irgendeine Kettenreaktion zu schaffen,
vielleicht trifft man es dann einfach, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Damit mehr Energie frei wird, ah, yes, verstehe.
Siehste, heute haben wir wieder was gelernt.
Wie gesagt, mehr als in 10 Jahren Chemie.
Chemie habe ich eigentlich ehrlich gesagt gar nichts gelernt.
In Chemie hatten wir den übelsten Kacklehrer, das weiß ich noch.
Wir hatten erst, wir hatten in Chemie, hatten wir erst einen Lehrer,
der hatte keinen Bock, der war irgendwie noch ein Jahr oder so da,
dann ging der in Rente, also richtig, da hat der wirklich,
Motivation in Person, ja.
Und danach hatten wir eine Lehrerin,
und das ist jetzt nicht, weil ich die schlecht reden will oder so,
aber die war wirklich alkoholabhängig.
Das hast du auch gemerkt, ich habe es damals nicht gecheckt,
aber später kam das dann raus und dann war es mir auch klar,
weil die hat wirklich, die hat es mit Chemie wahrscheinlich zu ernst genommen
und musste das alles ein bisschen ausbringen.
Die saß wirklich, vorne im Unterricht saß die da
und ich dachte immer entweder, die ist krank oder so,
oder ich dachte eigentlich im Unterricht, die stirbt bald, ja,
weil die saß immer vorne, die Lehrerin hat die ganze Zeit,
so hat die vorne gesessen und ich habe mir gedacht,
Alter, was ist mit der denn los?
Ich habe gedacht, das nächste Jahr ist die quasi F.
Nee, aber im Nachhinein hat man rausgekriegt,
die war ein bisschen, ja, so ein bisschen zu vieles gut nach und zu.
Also wie gesagt, ich habe da echt gedacht,
das nächste Jahr ist die unter der Erde,
aber im Nachhinein, als das dann rausgekommen ist,
dass die alkoholabhängig ist, da war es eigentlich klar.
Hat die Oberstufenleitung gehabt?
Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Oh, das ist auch schlecht.
Battlefield 3, beste, beste.
Oh, hier, Big Brain, da.
Also das wusste ich, das ist ja auch der hauptsächliche Grund,
warum man das macht, weil es sich einfacher verarbeiten lässt
und mit diesem mit diesem Flussmittel fließt das ja dann auch schön.
Also wunderbar eigentlich.
U-Gym, subscribt.
17 Monate, das ist ja massive Subscription.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Aha.
Der Chat ist heute wirklich wieder high IQ.
Ich sehe es hier schon.
Okay, also, Leute, ich wollte das nochmal ausprobieren mit meinem Setup.
Ich hatte heute nichts Großartiges vor,
aber so insgesamt muss man sagen, ich glaube,
ist jetzt von der Beleuchtung her und von der ganzen Geschichte
ist es deutlich besser als die letzten Male.
Die 200 Euro Elgato müssen sich ja,
also Elgato-Dingspunkt, Licht hier müssen sich ja auch gelohnt haben.
Was richtig cool ist, also was man dem Setup gut gefällt,
man hat keine Schatten mehr, sonst hatte ich hier das Ringlight drum herum
und hier in der Mitte hat es einen Schatten,
weil dann das Handy davor hing und so, das war kacke.
Und jetzt hast du das Ringlight und oben in der Mitte,
also hier so, da ist das Handy.
Eigentlich ganz gut.
Gibt es einen Discord-Channel? Ja, haben wir.
Ach so, zum Vorschlagen von Videos kannst du irgendwo rein posten.
Was auch immer.
Ich glaube, wir haben irgendwas für Themenvorschläge oder so,
haben wir, glaube ich.
Ja, okay, Chat, das war es.
Ich wollte nur mal ausprobieren, ob das Setup funktioniert.
Setup funktioniert, dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder.
Ich mache mich jetzt schon vom Acker.
Oder gibt es noch irgendwelche wichtigen Dinge,
die wir besprechen müssen?
Ich wollte ja nur mal ausprobieren.
Alles geht, ich schaue mal kurz,
ob ich nicht irgendwelche Subs vergessen habe.
Nope.
Exzellent.
Ja, ja, Themenvorschläge kannst du rein machen.
Okay, also, alles klar, Leute.
Wir sehen uns morgen. Bis dann, machts gut, CU.
Was gibt es morgen? Da bin ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Vielleicht gibt es morgen keinen Stream
und ich nehme endlich mal wieder ein Video auf.
Was heißt endlich mal wieder? Ich nehme wieder ein Video auf.
Boomer im Homeoffice gibt es dann als Thema.
Und vielleicht machen wir morgen Mittag ein bisschen Battlefield 3.
Mal gucken.
Also, alles klar, machts gut, bis dann, CU.